[Music]
this is our future the United States of
America endures a second Civil War
killing Millions immediately after that
a World War begins nuclear weapons are
used billions are killed the aftermath
leaves the Earth in Ruins electric grids
are down food becomes scarce disease is
rampant Society breaks down then in 2038
all computers go offline civilization
has set back several hundred years the
world enters a second Dark Age only by
changing events in our past and present
can we avoid this nightmare of a future
in 1998 in a small town in Florida John
Teeter was born in the year 2036 John a
temporal Soldier would be sent back in
time his mission saved the world
foreign
on July 29 1998 Art Bell host of Coast
to Coast AM was running what he called
open timelines he wanted calls from
people who claimed to be Time Travelers
obviously this brought out plenty of
Kooks but then a fax came in that felt
eerily real dear art
ifacts when I heard other time travelers
flowing in from any time past the year
2500 A.D please let me explain
time travel was invented in 2034
offshoots of certain successful Fusion
reactor research allowed scientists at
CERN to produce the world's first
contained Singularity engine the basic
design involves rotating singularities
inside of magnetic field by altering the
speed and direction of rotation you can
travel both forward and backward in time
time itself can be understood in terms
of connected lines when you go back in
time you travel on your original
timeline when you turn your Singularity
engine off a new timeline is created due
to the fact that you and your time
machine are now there some interesting
outcomes of this are one unit yourself I
have done it often even taken a younger
version of myself alone for a few rides
before returning myself to the new
timeline and going back to mine two you
can alter history in the new universe
that you have just created most of the
time the changes are subtle
sometimes I'll notice car models that
don't exist or books that come out late
unfortunately it was also discovered
that anyone going forward in time for my
2036 hit a brick wall in the year 2564.
please pray that we discover the reason
why there is no apparent future after 25
64. a few days later a second fax came
in Dear Mr Bell I'm glad you're back I
faxed this information to you the day
before you left the air as I said then
I'm a time traveler I have been on this
world line since April of this year and
I plan to leave soon
typically Time Travelers do not
purposely affect the world lines they
visit however this mission is unusually
long and I've grown attached to some of
the people I have met here anyway for my
own reasons I have decided to help this
world line by sharing information about
the future with a few people in the hope
that it will help their future I realize
my claims are a bit difficult to accept
so I will send the following once I know
you have received this fax
a few pages from the operations manual
of my time machine
and a few colored photographs of my
vehicle
if you wish to contact me I will be
happy to share with you the nature of
time the physics of time travel and some
of the events of your future Art Bell
didn't hear from this person again which
was too bad because he offered to show
proof everybody who heard that broadcast
wanted to see a working time machine
learn the science behind time travel and
know events from the future two years
later they would get their wish
a little over two years after the time
traveler sent faxes to Art Bell a user
who called himself time traveler zero
and later John Teeter created an account
on a message board called the time
travel Institute on November 2nd 2000 he
submitted his first post greetings and a
time traveler from the year 2036
I am on my way home after getting an IBM
5100 computer system from the year
1975. my time machine is a stationary
Mass temporal displacement unit
manufactured by General Electric
the unit is powered by two topspin dual
positive singularities that produce a
standard offset tipler sinusoid
I will be happy to post pictures of the
unit
now before we get into it I have to be
fair and say there were plenty of people
on The Message Board who were skeptical
who wouldn't be but John Teeter was very
specific and seemed to have very
specialized knowledge first off a tipler
sinusoid or a tipler cylinder is a
theoretical method of time travel
outlined in a paper by Frank tipler in
1974 so we're off to an interesting
start but what about the IBM 5100 why
would anyone with the technology to
travel through time need a computer that
was in 2036 about 80 years old well John
Teeter said the 5100 was needed to debug
Legacy computer programs in 2036 because
Unix has a problem in 2038 well that's
true remember the Y2K scare the fear was
hardware and software that measured the
year in two digits would freak out when
the year changed from 99 to 0-0 now the
world didn't end as some people
anticipated but Y2K did cause some
sporadic problems something similar is
going to to happen in 2038 and it could
be worse Unix systems measure time in
seconds a Unix timestamp is the number
of seconds since January 1st 1970. so
the Unix timestamp one minute after that
date is 60. the time stamp one hour
after that date is 3600 and up it goes
as I write this the Unix timestamp is
166-413-1870 so about 1.6 billion
seconds without getting too geeky a
32-bit integer can only go as high as
about 2.1 billion the official last date
that a 32-bit system can recognize is
Tuesday January 19 2038 after that
things could get interesting new
interesting is never good it's not and
the way to solve this is by upgrading
systems to 64 bits how far in the future
does that get us well the max 64-bit
number is about 9.2 quintillion so that
gets us to the year 292 billion in
change oh that should be enough it will
be so what is an old computer have to do
with this well John Teeter said the IBM
5100 could help them debug Legacy code
and this is actually correct most
personal computers like the IBM 5100
could only support the basic programming
language but the 5100 had special
functionality that was hidden from the
public it could run programs written in
basic but it could also run APL programs
written for IBM mainframes that's useful
only the IBM Engineers who designed it
knew this secret they were afraid of how
competitors might use it in 2002 NASA
was buying old gear on eBay because that
was the only way to find Intel 8086
chips which they needed for various
missions so this is something that
happens so John teeter's first post
contained a lot of sound science and
information that wasn't well known at
the time but he was just getting started
John Teeter was very active on the
message board he would answer any
question anyone had he just wouldn't
talk about things like the stock market
or who would win the Super Bowl he said
he wasn't interested in helping anyone
get rich and even if he was he couldn't
remember who won a Super Bowl 35 years
ago but John Teeter also said that
predictions like that could be wrong
because he was from a different timeline
which he called A World line how he
explained it was imagine a cone where
the diameter of the cone is how
different the destination time is from
your own you enter the time machine at
the tip of the cone the further backward
or forward in time you go the larger the
Divergence Teeter said that when he
arrived in the year 2000 the diversions
was about one or two percent now that's
not a lot but it's enough where
different teams could win different
games what Teeter is describing is the
many worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics where anything that can
possibly happen does happen it just
happens in a different timeline Teeter
specifically referred to the Everett
wheeler model with which again shows a
good grasp of quantum mechanics and the
scientists working in the field and even
though John Teeter wouldn't make Petty
predictions he would describe his life
and the future in detail John said that
in the early 2000s there would be a Waco
type event every month that steadily
gets worse the Civil War in the United
States starts in 2004 and the war
affects everyone at the age of 13 John
joins a shotgun infantry unit called the
Fighting Diamondbacks and the war
continues until 2015 and finally ends
with what he calls a very short World
War III taking advantage of America's
weakness Russia attacked cities in the
United States China and Europe the
United States retaliated and as a result
three billion people are killed the only
people to survive are the ones who don't
live in the big cities in the aftermath
of the war the United States is split
into five separate regions each region
elects its own president and all five
presidents serve a new very diminished
federal government in the capital which
has been moved to Omaha Nebraska in 2036
I live in Central Florida with my family
I'm currently stationed at an army base
in Tampa
a World War in 2015 killed nearly 3
billion people
the people that survived grew closer
together
life is centered on the family and in
the community
I cannot imagine living even a few
hundred miles away from my parents
there's no large industrial complex
creating masses of useless food and
recreational items
food and livestock has grown and sold
locally
people spend much more time reading and
talking together face to face
religion is taken seriously and everyone
can multiply and divide in their heads
this new world is now a simpler Place
more focus is placed on family the
community and religion the biggest fear
John Teeter has is mad cow disease which
has become a worldwide pandemic John
transfers into a military unit with
seven other time travelers and their job
is to go back and try and prevent as
much environmental damage as possible
The Narrative John Teeter creates is
very detailed and I'll link to a page
where you can read every one of his
posts and even though people on The
Message Board were entertained and
fascinated they were skeptical they
wanted to know one can you tell us how
your time travel device works and two
can you show us a picture of it the
answer was yes and yes
foreign
posted diagrams of his time travel
device pictures of the operator's manual
and even pictures of the device itself
according to John time travel is
discovered in 2034 by scientists at CERN
using this breakthrough technology
General Electric actually creates
working time travel devices these
machines go through various iterations
and improvements the time travel unit
John Teeter uses is a c204 gravity
Distortion time displacement unit which
operates using micro singularities or
tiny black holes the source of power for
the c204 that allows it to distort and
manipulate gravity comes from two micro
singularities that were created captured
and cleaned at a much larger and
circular facility
the Dual event Horizons of each one in
their mass is manipulated by injecting
electrons under the surface of their
respective urbispheres
the electricity comes from batteries
the Breakthrough that will allow for
this technology will occur within a year
or so and CERN brings a larger facility
online
John Teeter talks about Cur black holes
which are black holes that rotate and
tippler cylinders now these are real
theories in physics that involve time
travel one of the most interesting
pieces of technology in John teeter's
time machine is called a variable
gravity lock system or vgl since the
machine only travels through time and
not space the vgl makes sure that the
Earth is in the same place in orbit when
it reaches its destination otherwise you
end up floating in space which is not
ideal the hard part of traveling through
time is not the bending of gravity but
the plotting of your course and holding
to the basic position in your
environment
this is done through a system called bgl
variable gravity lock
in effect it holds you to the Earth
during travel it periodically checks to
see that the field is not varied
if it doesn't stops and reverses course
or drops out at that point
buildings and other terrain features are
avoided in the same way
as soon as the vgo sensors pick up an
unexpected mass in the Target World line
it would shut down
the c204 has an array of computers
clocks and sensors to get you to the
correct day but because timelines get
more and more different the further
forward or back you go the unit maxes
out at about 60 years someone asked him
about traveling back a thousand years
John said that you wouldn't even
recognize that world the Distortion unit
reaches its Target destination by using
very sensitive gravity sensors and
atomic clocks
the basic unit of calculation is the
second
so we guess in a sense you do dial in a
date and the computer system controls
the Distortion field
at maximum power the unit I have is
capable of traveling about 10 years an
hour
unfortunately time travel is not an
exact science
there is inherent error in chaos in the
computer's ability to make accurate
calculations
based on the current technology of the
clocks and sensors
Distortion units are only accurate to
about 60 years or so
no in 2036 we were unable to travel back
1 000 years due to the error rate in the
system
the Divergence between the world line of
origin and the Target World blind would
be too great
if one were to try to travel back that
far history would look nothing like what
you would expect
in other words if I wanted to go back 2
000 years and meet Christ there is a
better than average chance I would end
up on a world line where he was never
born
hello the one what are those pitches it
looked like a bucket seat with a seat
belt yep that's because on John teeter's
first trip the time machine was mounted
inside a 67 Chevy no I guess the
DeLorean is too on the nose well the
reason for the Chevy and why John later
moved the machine to a truck is because
the c204 is heavy it needs a vehicle
with a suspension that can handle the
weight plus the time machine has to be
mobile since it only travels through
time and not space you have to drive to
your physical destination first and then
move through time he chose those
Vehicles because they blend into the
times he was traveling to yo did he say
what it feels like to time travel like
it doesn't hurt does your face get all
stretchy well John Teeter does talk
about this the gravity field generated
by the unit overtakes you very quickly
you feel a tug toward the unit similar
to Rising quickly in an elevator and it
continues to rise based on the power
setting the unit is working under
at 100 percent power the constant pull
of gravity can be as high as 2G as we're
moored depending on how close you are to
the unit
there are no serious side effects but I
try to avoid eating before a flight
no bright flash of light is seen
outside the vehicle appears to
accelerate as the light is bent around
it
we have to wear sunglasses or close our
eyes as this happens due to a short
burst of ultraviolet radiation
personally I think it looks like you're
driving under a rainbow
after that it appears to fade to black
and remains totally black until the end
is turned off
we're advised to keep the windows closed
as a great deal of heat builds up
outside the car
the gravity feel also traps a small air
pocket around the car it acts as your
only O2 Supply unless your green
compressed air with you
I can never time travel because of my
IBS uh that's TMI um no it's IBS
never mind naturally people were
skeptical of all this technology but
John Teeter didn't really care my goal
is not to be believed
most people do not take news of the war
very well but I find that everyone
believes it's inevitable
I watch every day what you are doing as
a society
why do you sit by and watch your
Constitution being torn away from you
you willfully poison food by
manufactured products no one needs and
turn an uncaring eye away from millions
of people suffering and dying all around
you
perhaps I should let you all in on a
little secret
no one likes you in the future this time
period is looked at as being full of
lazy self-centered civically ignorant
sheep
perhaps you should be less concerned
about me and more concerned about that
[Music]
teeter's face was never seen his voice
was never heard and John Teeter is not
his real name so there's not much we
know about him but one person did have a
close relationship with John or at least
claimed to Pamela Moore Pamela was very
active on the message boards and spent a
lot of time chatting with John over I am
before John Teeter left he said he would
make a departure video and send it to
Pamela well how is she supposed to know
that video is legit well because John
provided Pamela with a secret song to
act as a password this is something only
the two of them know so she could
identify imposters but to this day the
departure video has not arrived and
Pamela has never revealed the secret
song on March 24 2001 John Teeter would
leave his final message and some words
of wisdom I will be leaving this world
line shortly and this will be my final
post
there are only a handful of people who
will know exactly when I will be leaving
and I'm sure they will let you know when
I'm gone
in the last few days I've found your
choice topics quite interesting
and from an objective Viewpoint I think
it collectively answers one of their own
questions
if time travel is real where are all the
time travelers
in the past I've stated that quite
frankly you all scare the hell out of me
and I'm sure other temporal drivers
would feel the same
but now I have an expanded explanation
a while ago I related an experience I
had with my parents while we were
driving down a highway
every now and then would pass someone
who was in obvious distress with their
vehicle
I was amazed that so many people could
pass them live without stopping to help
their explanation Was Fear
the risk of helping someone was too
great and with today's technology it
probably had a cell phone anyway
if they didn't the walk to a gas station
would be good for them and teach them
the lesson for running out of gas
this is why Time Travelers do not show
themselves
in trying to help you we put ourselves
at Great risk and there's really no
point to it
I already know you won't pay any
attention or believe me because we've
already been through it on this world
line besides I think the walk to the gas
station will do you some good
I also want to thank Pamela for helping
me with the email and everyone else who
asked intelligent and insightful
questions
I've learned a great deal
my parting thought revolves around
something JC has been harping on since
day one
no I did not have a secret agenda but
I've been paying a great deal of
attention to your world line
my interaction with you was not a direct
Mission parameter but it was a secondary
Mission protocol based on standing
orders given to all temporal drivers
that secondary objective is basically to
gather as much information about a world
line based on a set of observable
variables when we first arrived
Your World Lighting at those conditions
what amazes me is why no one here
wonders why why 2K didn't hit them at
all bring a gas can with you when the
car dies on the side of the road
farewell John
and John Teeter was gone and hasn't been
heard from since
but that was really just the beginning
of the legend
[Music]
when the John Teeter story first landed
in 2001 it was a sensation but as the
years went on we've been able to see the
accuracy of John's predictions John
predicted a Civil War in the United
States that would begin in 2005.
obviously that didn't happen but you can
make the case that America has never
been more divided than it is today
thanks Twitter 20 of adults in a recent
survey said they believe a civil war is
likely within the next 10 years that's a
high percentage and John Teeter
predicted a nuclear war in 2015 and that
too didn't happen but considering
current world events the last time we
were this close to nuclear war was the
Cuban Missile Crisis I actually think
we're in more danger now he predicted
there would be no Olympic Games after
2004. and he was wrong about that but
there were no 2020 Olympics John Teeter
did get a few things right there was a
mad cow disease outbreak in the early
2000s to America's First confirmed case
of bovine spongiform Encephalitis in six
years
BSE is mad cow disease a potentially
deadly brain wasting infection that can
be transferred to humans when John
Teeter was posting in early 2001 most
people were still accessing the internet
with a dial-up modem John said in the
future the internet would look more like
the current cell phone system that's
exactly right he said that in the future
the entertainment industry would be
decentralized and anyone would be able
to create video which could be watched
by many people more people watch YouTube
than watch the networks or even go to
the movies John Teeter was right again
he predicted breakthroughs in high
energy physics at CERN in 2013 the Higgs
boson was confirmed Stephen Hawking
originally thought that everything that
enters a black hole disappears forever
Peter said that Stephen Hawking made a
mistake about this Stephen Hawking did
later change his mind now many of these
predictions could be dismissed as
educated guesses by someone who is
intelligent and knew a lot about science
and technology but there's no denying
that John was right as for the
predictions John Teeter got wrong True
Believers and there are still a lot of
those always fall back on the many
worlds theory Sure many of John teeter's
predictions were wrong in our timeline
but they came true in other timelines
and there's no way to prove this wrong
but if you look closely at the John
Teeter story you do find inconsistencies
you also find Convenient coincidences
because of these problems with the story
many believe that John Teeter was a hoax
and if that's true then who was the real
John Teeter well there are a few
Suspects
[Music]
whenever anyone does a story about John
Teeter and who he actually may be there
are a few names that always pop up the
first is Joseph Matheny he's described
as a writer and trans media artist and
he's mostly known for aung's hat which
was one of the first alternate reality
or real-time interactive games and
Matheny makes a good case he said that
he along with three other people
developed the John Teeter story as a fun
experiment to see if they could develop
an internet myth mission accomplish
Matheny won't divulge who the other
three people are because they're pretty
high up in the entertainment industry
and have reputations to protect but a
lot of the story tracks Matheny says the
time machine we see in the fuzzy photos
was created by a prop designer who's
worked on major movies and John Teeter
fans have been able to identify pieces
of the time machine that are actually
real things Matheny says the reason the
messages often have different tones is
because they were written by different
people on the team Matheny was
responsible for character development
and the reason that John tater's story
is so similar to John Connors is because
it was intentional now I've heard and
read some interviews with Matheny and at
first I was skeptical initially I didn't
think he had the tech or science
background to flesh out the details in
the John Teeter story I was very wrong
Matheny was involved in Tech since the
80s he worked with Adobe and Netscape in
the early days and holds a few patents
also his game ong's hat had references
to theoretical physics he had add the
tech shops and a track record in
creating online myths he could have
definitely pulled this off still I'd
love to see hard evidence Matheny won't
provide any and when asked he gets
pretty annoyed he says believe him or
don't he doesn't care I think that after
20 years he's sick of people asking him
about John Teeter but there are more
people to look at
[Music]
the other name that comes up in the John
Teeter story is Larry Haber and the
Haber Brothers Larry Haber is a
florida-based entertainment attorney he
claims to represent John teeter's mom K
and the Teeter family hey how does a
lawyer sleep I don't know how oh first
he lies on one side and then he lies on
the other
hey
good one now I've seen and read a number
of interviews with Larry Haber he
definitely does not have the technology
or science background to create John
Teeter but his brothers do Richard Haber
is an I.T administrator and Maury Haber
is a very senior cyber security
professional Mori also has a lot of
experience writing about technology and
if you go down the John Teeter rabbit
hole on YouTube You'll eventually run
into a channel called hoax Hunter Run by
John Rasmus Houston and I'll link to his
channel below now John has done a ton of
research on the subject he's tracked P.O
boxes he's done text comparisons of Mori
haber's writing to John teeter's posts
he's tracked all the usernames from John
teeter's message board I mean this is
exhaustive research he's convinced that
John Teeter is actually Maury Haber who
eventually enlisted his lawyer brother
to represent the story what is a lawyer
get when you give him Viagra what taller
I have a problem with lawyers do you
I've been divorced three times what do
you think Larry Haber has been attached
to John Teeter for years not only does
he claim to represent the Teeter family
in 2003 he registered the John Teeter
Foundation LLC a for-profit business and
this LLC published John teeter's posts
as a book called A Time Traveler's tale
Larry Haber also registered John Teeter
as a trademark in 2007.
this lawyer claims to represent the
Teeter family right yeah and at the same
time he's got businesses and books that
is making money from this thing that's
right isn't that a conflict of interest
I think it is but I guess Larry Haber
and the Teeter family are okay with it
he won't say Hey how do you get a lawyer
out of a tree I'll cut the rope
Joseph Matheny said he had someone reach
out to the publisher of Larry haber's
book and get it pulled Larry Haber can't
confirm that Matheny did this but he did
confirm that the book is out of print
and doesn't know why
torpedo the lawyer that's what it looks
like he's okay in my book hey what do
you have when a lawyer is buried up to
his neck in sand what do you have not
enough sand yeah oh
baby in Larry haber's defense even
though he represents the Teeter family
he doesn't claim to believe the story he
says he doesn't know one way or the
other and doesn't care he's just working
for his client and making money from his
client yeah and that Pamela Morris said
she was sent a copy of Larry haver's
book signed by John with a song quoted
at the end who is it the secret song
nope how do you know if a lawyer is
lying
his lips are moving
[Music]
over 20 years later and the John Teeter
story still fascinates people honestly I
had never considered doing the story
because it's been done so many times but
it's one of the most requested topics on
the channel I think the reason we love
time travel stories is because it all
comes down to possibilities and
opportunities a story about a possible
future especially such a frightening one
gives us an opportunity to reflect on
our present and choose a path to avoid
that dark future or it gives us a chance
to prepare for it think of how useful it
would be if someone came back from that
future to warn us to give us the exact
steps to follow to ensure our survival
well before John Teeter disappeared he
did just that do not eat or use products
from any animal that is fed and needs
parts of its own dead
do not kiss or have intimate relations
with anyone you do not know
learn basic sanitation and water
purification
be comfortable around Firearms learn to
shoot and clean a gun
get a good first aid kit and learn to
use it find five people within 100 miles
that you trust with your life and stay
in contact with them
get a copy of the U.S Constitution and
read it
less
hit a bicycle and two sets of spare
tires ride it 10 miles a week
consider what you would bring with you
if you had to leave your home in 10
minutes and never return
I don't know if the story of John Teeter
is real I don't think we'll ever know
but still my family is taking his advice
we've got the first aid kit the bicycle
and lots of ammo we're prepared for the
future that John described at least as
best as we can be and it's okay if you
don't believe that John Teeter is from
the future it's a story that anyone
would be skeptical of but be skeptical
of John Teeter at your own risk me
I'm not willing to take the chance
thank you so much for hanging out with
me today my name is AJ that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment share that stuff
really helps the channel and like most
topics we cover on the channel today's
topic was recommended by you if there's
a story you'd like to see or learn more
about go to the yfiles.com tips and
special thanks to our patrons who made
this channel possible I'm amazed by your
generosity and if you'd like to support
the channel consider becoming a member
on patreon or grabbing something from
the Wi-Fi store
with a Heckle fish t-shirt I don't know
if your friends will be jealous but they
will have questions that's gonna do it
until next time be safe be kind and know
that you are appreciated
[Music]
thank you